breaking news in ukraine where soldiers
trapped inside a marijuana steel works
may be making their last stand against
russian forces a ukrainian military
drone filmed gigantic explosions rocking
that plant the last holdout in the city
that russia now controls british
intelligence believes there's new
urgency for russia to seize that
facility for propaganda reasons charlie
dagetta is in ukraine for us once again
charlie good morning some soldiers
making a last stand there but there are
new efforts to help civilians who are
trapped in marijuana
good morning to you tony yes we can
confirm an evacuation is currently
underway as we speak and it is going
well according to the red cross they're
reluctant to share any details until
everybody is out safely
in between the bombing and the bullets
at the besieged steel plant rescue teams
has somehow managed to evacuate almost
500 civilians
yet the gun battles have continued and a
russian separatist commander says
ukrainian forces have run out of
ammunition
by the 9th of may we'll try to take it
all he said
that's victory day when russia
celebrates the defeat of nazi germany
conquering mariupol for good would hand
president putin a badly needed trophy
at a horrific human cost survivors
describe a living hell and many are
psychologically scarred by their ordeal
international red cross spokesman chris
hanger told us when our teams met these
civilians they were obviously
devastated they have not seen the sky
for over
two months and and the moment that they
they got out they saw their city their
home and destroyed completely destroyed
so some people were asking actually for
a priest some people were were just
crying and some people were just just
silent 25 year old tatiana trotsk
cuddled her dog daisy and marveled at
the blue sky and bright sun
i hope there will never be any kind of
booms here she said just fireworks and
thunder maximum
having survived the russian onslaught in
bucha herself jana melnichenko drove
down here to meet her brother and mother
who fled from azov just north of
mariupol can you describe what it was
like there
velocity
it was hard we didn't have any water no
internet connection we were hiding in
the basement alexi told us and the
russians looted the supermarkets
is the whole family back together now
and yet this whole region is bracing for
much darker days to come
the pentagon has confirmed that the us
has been sharing intelligence with
ukrainian forces since this conflict
began we have now learned that some of
that intelligence was used to help sink
the moskva battleship last month
officials tell cbs news u.s intelligence
provided the location of the ship in the
black sea but had no role in the
decision to strike it
eureka
charlie dagda in our cbs news crew thank
you